well I think that you do need
immigration reform I think it's a big
problem that the Prime Minister David
Cameron set is no ifs no buts net
migration target that is now in tatters
and it was a grand promise and to not
have any practical plans I think that
ended up undermining public confidence
you know and not supported the whole
system to make it fair I think there are
different reforms that we should have
including stronger border controls we've
said we should have a thousand more
border staff to make sure that visas are
enforced and proper checks are done I
also think you have to deal with the
problem of exploitation where you have
employers and recruitment agencies
exploiting immigration to undercut wages
and jobs that's one of the biggest
problems we face but we're talking about
legal migrants here aren't we we're
talking about people who are coming from
predominantly within the EU that people
it's not just Romania and Bulgaria it is
the u15 the Old Europe if you like and
and that those are coming here to work
to contribute to the economy
we've always had people coming to
Britain contribution to the economy and
that will be important for a future
further to make sure that we get top
talent and investment in our country
immigrations also got to be controlled
and managed so that the system is fair
you know you talk about immigration from
Europe is obviously been an increase in
immigration from outside Europe as well
when it comes to Europe I think one of
the biggest challenges is about low
skilled migration being used to under
parked wages and jobs and that's unfair
on everyone it's unfair on people who
are being exploited who come here to
work hard but it's also unfair on local
people who see their wages and their
jobs being undercut and we've seen
problems like the minimum wage not being
enforced terms and conditions being
undermined recruitment agencies who are
only recruiting from abroad that is not
fair action should be taken on that kind
of enforcement and that would reduce the
demand for low-skilled labor but also
help support our economy so we're not
just dependent on low-skilled jobs isn't
one of the key factors here though a
good news story for us economic
prosperity here in the UK compared to
the eurozone is pulling people here
well it's important that our economy
should grow we've obviously had real
problems with the economy over very many
years but there's also probably the not
we're not seeing wage growth were seeing
too many people now on zero-hours
contracts people feeling left behind
people feeling exploited if you don't
deal with those sorts of problems then
even if the economy is growing most
people aren't feeling it and that's not
fair so you're right that there's a
wider issue about what's happening in
the economy I think we need for example
to see far more apprenticeships for
school leavers and far more support for
those sorts of quality jobs for the
future rather than just seeing the shift
to temporary zero contract work and we
should be taking action against that